now the washington times is reporting
that doj has axed at least a half dozen
judges hired during the trump years
including two this month in arlington
virginia and installing judges deemed to
be friendlier to the immigrants whose
cases they hear one of those ousted
judges matthew o'brien joins me now
mr o'brien you describe this as a
weaponization
of the immigration courts explain
well that's exactly what it is the
immigration courts are supposed to give
people who are seeking to remain in the
united states or violated the
immigration law a fair review of any
claims that they have made the biden
administration is trying to turn the
immigration court into essentially a
free candy store so that anyone who
appears in front of the immigration
court winds up getting some kind of
benefit or being allowed to stay in the
united states and that's not what the
courts were designed to do
and the backlog that exists now with
this
massive crush of humanity i know you
just saw the report
uh at the border yuma del rio sector all
throughout texas
what is this going to do to the
immigration courts
now
well the biden administration is in the
process of ordering ice to dismiss all
of the cases that are currently before
it so they seem to be
taking a creative approach to reducing
the backlog by simply not pursuing the
cases and releasing these people into
the interior of the united states they
also seem to be in the strange position
of dismissing immigration judges who are
appointed under president trump and then
trying to replace them with people who
meet their own ideological framework so
none of this is a recipe for trying to
deal with the issue and reduce the
backlog in any kind of a meaningful way
and it leaves me wondering who is
looking out for the interest the
american people in this whole
transaction well not them that's for
sure and i want to play the
administration line courtesy of biden's
homeland security chief
we continue to enforce the laws of this
country we continue to remove
individuals who do not qualify for
relief under the laws of this country
judge is that accurate given what you've
seen
no it's not remotely remotely accurate i
worked with ellie mayorkis when i was at
uscis
he follows a a party line uh that's
dictated to him by the democratic party
and its globalist agenda he's not
interested in enforcing the law and
what the immigration courts and what ice
are doing right now is certainly not
consistent with a law and order approach
to all of this essentially ice is
ignoring the immigration laws that it
doesn't like and the biden
administration is ordering the courts to
be complicit in this and they're busy
trying to remove anyone that took an
enforcement approach of applying the law
to the facts amnesty by judicial removal
judge we appreciate you thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else